estamos la bolita de 5 ansiosos por
saber que sacamos en la materia
pasa amigos decía tranquilo profesor o
profesora y el profesor me dice
y entonces regresa nos dice si pasa
conciencia
amigos hablando en las manos dice espero
haber pasado
profesor diga bueno es procesable dice
pasaste
pero amigos que 70
pero nosotros hicimos 70 la materia por
lo menos estás del otro lado no estás
del lado en el que se quedaron en otra
mate
estas de este lado junto con es de 180
esos 70
pero bueno fuera de eso un día
platicando fuera del salón de clases
estamos jugando estábamos ahí con el
café
para pasar el mate me dijo haye
no me lo vas a creer pero tú te acuerdas
que también mis cerramientos reprobados
mis mis actividades en donde lo mejor yo
si le dije pero es que mi hijo es que
fuera de todo eso el día del examen
final que me habían dado la fecha yo
sabía que me tenía que esforzar yo sabía
que el pasar este examen no iba a ser
sencillo ni va a ser cuestión de un día
dos días tres días cuatro o seis lo que
ustedes quieran pero iba a ser cuestión
de un esfuerzo
él se puso las pilas el menú comentó
factorías estudio práctico con los
amigos profesores un momento de fiesta
decíamos donde estaban y el día de hoy
sé que estaba estudiando para el examen
de la fe platicando ese mismo día me
estaba diciendo que para él no era lo
mismo
el estar escribiendo algo de español un
ensayo una investigación para historia
para cualquier otra materia que para
hacer cálculos en mateo en física porque
porque claro para en los cálculos en la
cabeza eran cosa de otro mundo
escribir investigar se le daban pero los
cálculos no pasaban por su cabeza
entonces yo me di a la tarea de verlo
después de la plática con el red social
también está la y todo lo demás y ver
que dicho y hecho en español los ensayos
consciente espectacular esos ensayos yo
los leía y veía un muy buen desire pero
llegamos a mate y preguntas de sumas no
sabía nada al azar
entonces decía pesos pero bueno
fuera de eso me di a la tarea de
analizar un lugar
siempre quieres o no ser una persona no
puedes meterte su cabeza no fundamental
y su moral es algo imposible o de plano
que mis respetos para 50 pero empiezan a
analizar su exterior y me empezó a
analizar mi exterior
qué pasó cuando lo analice vi a tres
factores indispensables para ellos mis
amigos que eran aquellas personas que me
acompañaban durante todo el trayecto de
los estudios estaban dentro del salón de
clases no apoyaban trabajábamos
pero también jugamos por otro lado
salimos así nos cantábamos los chismes
cualquier cosa
y después estaban por otro lado los
profesores los profesores que nunca te
preguntaron a mí no me han pasado que
llegaba a salir el examen de trabando
calificación final
y nunca te sacaste 68 pero tendrás tres
noches fuiste asesorías que hiciste para
pasar el 68 te voy a pasar los 70 porque
me los pasos que diste antes de tu
victoria o de lo que tú has logrado
claro que no porque ninguna persona o
por lo menos la mayoría se detiene a ver
los pasos que ha dado antes de llegar a
su destino
en este caso pongo como ejemplo a los
alumnos porque son aquellas personas que
yo vivo siento y veo y soy en estos
momentos yo a veces no me pongo a pensar
en los pasos que dado antes de demostrar
una calificación
no veo que me desvelé
yo solamente veo que hoy el día de hoy
presenté mi examen de mate y lo pasé
bien
pero tienes que ver los pasos que
existen antes de llegar aquí
fuera de los amigos y los profesores yo
vi a mis papás
estas personas que siempre están
acompañando te ganas oye tú puedes
éxitos
pero bueno
una pregunta
bueno bueno
bueno perfecto
porque a veces nuestro pas tampoco
alcanzan a ver esa perspectiva de los
pasos como sesiones que hemos dado para
llegar a su meta
el resultado final va agarrando claro
que de los pasos que has dado pero no
tienes que dejar de ver los pasos antes
de llegar a su destino
debemos de ver eso
hoy se cambió me pasó yo llegué con mi
dama un día muy emocionado el viernes y
decía mamá saque 70 y de 70
y no me va a decir porque está cocinando
sigue presionando y no se retoma la
palabra pero claro
yo dije que busca la persona más
con 600 más
no veo que en las últimas ocho noches y
que tenía la necesidad de presentar a
mis padres los pasos que había dado
antes de llegar a mi calificación final
o cualquier otra cosa que había dado
en este momento creo que me so cuando
comprendieron que sufrieron todos esos
pasos que había dado
para mi calificación en ese momento
empezaron a valorar
no solamente mi calificación sino los
pasos
lo cual este después de 30 puntos de
diferencia para cualquier alumno
ven sus pasos atrás y usted es justo en
su calificación más allá de un número
más allá de su meta final vean sus
partes que han transcurrido los pasos
que han caminado y los pasos que han
sufrido para llegar a su meta final
y vuelvo a repetir yo podemos los
estudiantes como ejemplo porque estoy lo
veo y lo siento claro que eso lo puede
ver de muchos ejemplos pero yo soy
estudiante y sé que antes de llegar a
una calificación tengo que ver todo lo
que he dado
para poder llegar
y la verdad es que me siento muy
contento claro mi proveedor su
excelencia
tampoco especie
pero me empiezo a fijar todos los pasos
que dado me siento orgulloso de ello
digo sabes que me siento orgulloso
porque
[Música]
pero la pasé porque me esforcé camine
dietas de la asesoría y para estudiar
y cuando di el cuarto lo que sea pasar
en ese momento supe que el resultado de
eso era pasar materia
algo que cualquier otro amigo o
estudiante y creo que están bien pero
vean sus pasos
vean por donde caminan lo que hacen lo
que sacrifican
antes de ver el resultado fuera de ello
después de verse orgullosos de todos los
pases que han dado
véanse orgullosos de sus resultados
pero vamos son importantes
toma sentido
por eso yo los invito como estudiantes
padres profesores humanos
que antes de ver sentirse orgullosos de
su meta vean los pasos que hay detrás de
ellas lo que han hecho y lo que se han
esforzado
[Aplausos]